dominique pradalié secrétaire générale
du snj elle est en direct avec monf
bonjour dominique pradalié merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
cette loi pose problème 1 à des milliers
de français qui manifestent mais aussi à
des ong pour ne citer qu'eux qui estime
que c'est une loi liberticide
expliquez-nous pour quelles raisons la
sécurité globale et répond à une
obsession a une obsession permanente du
ministre de l'intérieur est apparemment
du gouvernement de pouvoir contrôler
tout le monde tout le temps n'importe où
et surtout de ne pas se voir contester
donc les dalles wall e là là la
proposition de loi sécurité globale le
schéma national du maintien de l'ordre
les trois décret paru le 2 décembre
toutes ces textes c'est toutes ces
dispositions vont dans le même sens
c'est à dire un flicage massif et
généralisé de tous les français
alors si on comprend bien en tout cas
cet article 24
il est interdit de diffuser mais pas de
filmer est ce que dans les faits c'est
vraiment ça alors dans les faits les
forces de l'ordre agissent parfois
complètement en roue libre et saab a
occasionné de nombreux
dysfonctionnements de nombreuses
blessures de nombreuses illégalités de
nombreuses interpellations qu'ils sont
faites que pour que le miz de
l'intérieur puisse afficher du chiffre
et puis c'est tout dans les deux années
écoulées
plus de 200 journalistes ont été
empêchés de travailler
blessé injurié matériel saisi dans été
placé en garde à vue etc
les journées sont toujours dus de
quelques difficultés avec les forces de
l'ordre
mais c'était une fois passée une fois
par la 200 ça veut dire que c'est un
système
ça veut dire que c'est encourager
couvert en le ministre de l'intérieur en
toute impunité
nos plaintes
1019 n'avance pas les signalements
l'igpn son vin le gouvernement continue
d'essayer de patients ni l'égalité
d'ailleurs puisque la cnil vient de le
rappeler
les drones sont interdits pour le moment
c'était déjà une décision du conseil
d'état du mois mais ça n'avait pas
empêché le préfet de l'allemand
d'envoyer des drones sur toutes les
manifs que nous faisons depuis deux mois
et quand on dit ça concerne des milliers
de français ça concerne des dizaines de
millions de français
vous vous rendez compte que les
manifestations ont été suspendues
pendant un mois et elles reprennent dans
80 villes
mike leake au vide où malgré le
couvre-feu
malgré le l'hiver malgré les difficultés
des placements les français sont
toujours là pour dire on veut garder nos
libertés la coordination a qui appellent
à manifester notamment aujourd'hui
appellent également une rencontre avec
un exécutif avec emmanuel macron
pourquoi cette rencontre on n'a toujours
pas eu lieu
il faut demander à monsieur le président
de la république
pourquoi il ne répond jamais à nos
courriers je suis mal placé pour vous
répondre
donc autre mobilisation également le 30
janvier est ce que vous pensez que d'ici
là le gouvernement va peut être reculer
sur cette loi sécurité globale dans le
moment le gouvernement fait comme sa
stratégie depuis trois ans le pouce
c'est à dire je fais semblant de recul
et je fais un pas de côté mais j'avance
j'avance j'avance quand même j'avance en
toute illégalité tant pis j'avance quand
même j'interpelle 150 personnes comme ce
fut le cas le 12 décembre et je les mets
en garde à vue peu importe c'était à
paris donc peu importe
une ou deux personnes sont ressorties
sur ses 150 avec un rappel à la loi
sur 150 peu importe je fais du chiffre
je coupe les manifestations jean pesce
les manifestants de manifester
paisiblement
je laisse ainsi mis à des émeutiers et
on assimile maintenant au ministère de
l'intérieur les journalistes ou aux
participants alors que nous ne sommes
que des observateurs et des témoins les
justement on veut nous empêcher de
témoigner de ce qui se passe dans ce
pays est en ce moment à l'antenne en des
images en direct de la manifestation à
paris on rappelle est le cortège place
deux minimes doit se diriger vers celle
de la bastille madame pradalier ce que
vous constatez une dérive en quant au
respect de la liberté d'informer depuis
des années en france
est ce qu'il ya eu une dégradation il ya
une dégradation très nette à partir du
moment où les pouvoirs publics
nouvellement en place ont décidé un que
la propagande qui s'appelle
communication chez eux devaient
l'emporter sur le journalisme et en
dehors des entraves dont je vous ai
parlé il ya eu tous les journalistes
convoqués par les services secrets
quand il avait fait une enquête il ya eu
des tentatives de perquisition qui a
heureusement échoué notamment médiapart
il y a les gardes à vue permanente
il y a les journalistes qui ne peuvent
pas s'approcher leur dire lors des
évacuations de migrants que ce soit en
seine saint denis à grande synthe à
calais etc
donc je veux dire c'est permanent est
partout pourquoi parce que les plus
ultras défense de leurs savent très bien
qu'ils sont couverts par monsieur
darmanin
quoi qu'il arrive quoi qu'ils fassent
ils blessent il tabasse ils sont
couverts
ils empêchent les gens et de travailler
y sont couverts ils émettent en garde à
vue ils sont couverts
rien rien ne leur est jamais reproché
par leurs hiérarchies respectives
c'est ça que nous mettons en cause et
quand nous disons ça c'est pas
l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre
heureusement nous en connaissons
beaucoup qui travaille très bien qu'ils
sont très désarçonné est fou furieux de
voir que quelques-uns suffisent à gâcher
pour tous les publics
la confiance dans leurs forces de
sécurité dominique pradalié
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
rappelle que
secrétaire général du syndicat national
des journalistes le snj marciac mersiol